donc je m'appelle apostin Vanessa donc
j'ai 33 ans donc je suis divorcée j'ai
deux filles de 12 ans et de 8 ans donc
je suis ici pour représenter la création
d'emploi donc mon emploi donc suite à ma
séparation donc voilà j'ai recommencé ma
vie à zéro j'ai préparé un Capp
d'esthétique en 2010-211 donc j'ai eu
mon diplôme suite à ça j'ai commencé à
travailler
et donc je j'étais censé racheter la
l'Institut de mon ma patronne donc ça
c'est pas fait pour diverses raisons
donc j'ai je me suis lancée à mon compte
donc j'ai j'ai ouvert mon institut en
2013 en mai 2013 donc je fais des soins
visage des épilations du maquillage
l'extension de cil très prochainement de
la réflexologie plantaire et je
développe le côté corps très
prochainement bonjour je m'appelle
Jean-David Denard je représente la
société amolux donc je vais vous
présenter rapidement ma société je suis
conducteur de travaux de formation j'ai
travaillé dans le bâtiment amolux c'est
une agence de d'assistance à maîtrise
d'ouvrage c'est-à-dire que j'aide mes
clients à définir leur projet en
fonction de leur budget je les aide à
faire leur plan donc à déposer ensuite
leur permis de construire ensuite je
choisis les entreprises avec eux je suis
je fais ensuite tout ce qui est suivi et
coordination des travaux je vais mettre
en place un planning pour mon client
donc comme ça les délais sont respecter
je vais faire tout le suivi financier du
chantier avec le client je vais faire
une gestion comptable pour le client le
client saura exactement ce qu' va payer
à quel moment je contrôle également les
situations de travaux qui sont demandées
par les entreprise je valide en fonction
de l'avancement des travaux je me suis
inscrit dans le dans la catégorie
insertion euh parce que j'ai fait une
reconversion professionnelle j'étais à
la base en licence de STAPS
euh ça a pas fonctionné comme je voulais
parce que c'était pas vraiment ma voix
donc à un moment donné j'ai fait une
reconversion professionnelle par rapport
à un événement qui s'est passé dans ma
vie et j'ai décidé de créer mon
entreprise et mon étude de marché m'a
permis de voir justement que les clients
ont besoin d'aide ils ont on besoin
d'être accompagné et que leur projet de
construction qui est le projet d'une vie
en fait soit maîtrisé et qu'il y ait
quelqu'un qui suiv vraiment qui a un
professionnels extérieur aux aux
entreprises qui font la maison qui gèent
pour eux et qui les accompagnent bah
dans leur projet
d'une
euh je m'appelle C donc Laris donc je
suis gérante d'une entreprise de magasin
de de prête àorter euh d'occasions euh
qui se situe sur Saint-André donc je me
suis présentée aujourd'hui au challenge
créateur dans la catégorie de prix de
l'insertion actuellement je présente
donc des vêtements d'occasion et tout ce
qui est
accessoires type bijoux
fantaisie ceinture sac à main euh ma
motivation en fait ass surtout été le
fait que ma mère réside en Angleterre et
que j'ai pu voir euh
des magasins qui reprennent des
vêtements d'occasion pour les revendre
vraiment à très petit prix ça rejoint un
peu les thèm Maus abpier et cetera et
cetera mais concrètement j'achète les
vêtements d'occasion avec les
particuliers que je revends en mettant
en état et toujours à tout petit prix
alors moi mon poste à moi donc c'est
tout ce qui est la gestion de de du
magasin les parties
administratives donc j'accueille le
client j'accueille les personnes qui
veulent justement que je reprenne les
vêtements je délègue la responsabilité
du lavage et du repassage à une personne
que je paye en chque sessus je voulais
montrer surtout à aux jeunes créateurs
qui avaient autre chose à créer sur la
réunion que qu'il fallait vraiment
s'ouvrir un peu sur le monde pour
pouvoir apporter autre
chose